[Music]
every damn day it's a Florida man news
roundup which is why you gotta watch
this this is a compilation of a security
guard who is just farming on Instagram
you can tell like houston gage partly
based on his face so this is a florida
hospital security guard security guard
who got fired for posting videos of
himself Harding on Instagram don't worry
though Kevin James has already purchased
the rights in his life story that's
horrible
is this the rudest thing you can do at
work no I before I answer that I just
want to say how depressing it is that
our show will never be as popular and
before the commenters get after it not
because anything we're doing here is
wrong because no show will ever be that
popular there's like two million hits
it's hypnotic to watch the guy is the
whole thing there's nuances Romilly
surprise yeah he makes different little
faces and also it's just it's great
there's so much Instagram live him
getting fired yes and the guy was like
turn off Instagram live and I was like
look at all the people watching no one
watches Instagram live yeah and there
was all these comments like we're with
you a Florida man is continuing to
garden naked despite his neighbors
please to stop Wow he has promised to
trim his Bush that's like one of the
worst chores you could do naked also for
a man this is so dangerous
there's too much flopping around might
get caught in a fence who knows what's
gonna have you've got there daily that's
why I don't do anything negging weird
naked but I love the regular weird stuff
that we all know what I'm told
I do all that washing dishes washing
dishes you know no I bake pies bring me
to work and one point my wife she is
like a big fan to be a naked growing up
like she grew up in the house of mostly
women I go but I mostly guys we love
they have clothes on but she for like a
year she got me to just live that Nikki
it's addictive I truly lost I didn't
hear anything you said it because I just
started thinking about you naked I
missed like the whole like the last six
senses put a real fit our next headline
is at a Jacksonville Florida zoo an
elephant got out of its enclosure and
went for a brief stroll and the elephant
immediately returned to its cage when he
saw what the rest of Jacksonville
Florida looks like anybody read this is
where I show off that I did I read to
the yes the Neverland Ranch off the wall
and tried to beat it out of the zoo but
I'm sorry that these puns are so bad
[Applause]
truly a thriller I don't know I got you
know do you know any Michael Jackson
song what a Florida woman's dirty
dancing reenactment caused her to be
thrown in jail turns out you can't put
baby in her corner for six weeks without
parole was she that all food it was like
look we got no what she just so freely
she was just like belligerent refusing
to leave and then she walked out of the
wine store and then told her and her
friend she told her friend to come back
in and then they staged the iconic like
you run dirty days to the movie where
they were sitting in the chair and they
had the water splash on them that's
Flashdance
but a bangle on over top of me which you
sit in the chair Natasha and I tried to
reenact that dirty dancing when we were
in Scotland which I think that here
comes out next week but it's really hard
it's so hard the amount of upper-body
strength that you need to lift somebody
up just with your hand they happen to
have it so we just didn't use that tape
because it looked too good and we're
like this copyright issue is there a
movie a reenactment that would get you
thrown in jail
American Psycho Pied paul blart he got
arrested nobody would hire me I'll just
be in the mod I wouldn't leave it I
gotta go did I will get arrested for
helping security at a mall okay would
you arrest this woman for staging this
in your wine store
oh man I don't know I bet that guy was
tired he's in the liquor store let have
a little fun I was outside of my liquor
store and this guy tried to like what
are you like hustle me he had a bag of
broken glass already in a bag
he bumped into me and dropped the bag so
then it was you know makes the sound of
broken glass and then I was just like I
was like oh I'm sorry
you know cuz do you bump into somebody
he wanted me to buy him liquor it was a
pretty good hustle that's a great
production every other day for the rest
of the why do you like have you ever
been hustled every day that's like the
same two guys who live in my
neighborhood and they like and spot me
from a mile away even when I'm not
wearing this sweatshirt they're like I'm
always like one time I yelled at one of
them like no enough like and you know
I'm nice
okay last headline a Florida House
candidate who claims she was abducted by
aliens is now being endorsed by a major
newspaper clarify a major newspaper in
Florida is anything with a size 14 fonts
major newspaper actually it was the
Miami Herald for so many people this is
crazy
yes what do you mean what do I mean it's
embarrassing for the Miami Herald it's
embarrassing for the person that the
incumbent that this lady's running
against you know even his paper went
with the alien abduction story person
it's embarrassing for the Republican
Party that they couldn't find just a
regular racist yeah there's plenty to be
embarrassed about it is embarrassing
Ryan doesn't believe that alien
abductions are real and you do yeah do
you think yeah have you had like an
alien experience no but like they bet
they're real they're gonna ask for her
to communicate they've been
communicating with her since she was
seven years old the thing is interesting
to me as she said that they told her
events that would happen but has yet to
tell us any of those events lose a race
for the House her platform is really
good she wants to like lower student
loans okay she wants to fix the credit
course system she wants to help the
homeless like it's all very good yeah
and and she's very Pro anal you know
it's me shout out comes from Mike's
rambles who wrote in response to our
question what's the ultimate 2018
Halloween costume and Mike's said that
Bank C shredded painting you wear a
giant frame and hold a fake red balloon
and some black trousers then print a
large photo of your legs best to wear
something bright
shred them into a skirt yeah
thanks Mike you know what he's invited
to our holiday party 3:45 all right now
it's time for a Florida man game it's
called Florida man limbs I'm gonna show
you a Florida man real headline and
you're gonna fill in the blank
it's see if we can guess what it really
is so our first one is Florida candidate
poses with blank after being questioned
about her credentials resume he's just
lucky holding up a resume I better some
kind of like dead Safari animal Jordan
was the closest it's fake diploma
diploma all right next one Florida man
attempts to rob blank demands money and
blank very queen he Rob's a Dairy Queen
and what does he demand money in a cone
gas station lottery tickets mmm that's
good I'm gonna prices right you or
whatever that is and gas near you so
Burger King and he demands burger Chris
was the closest man attempts to rob
Krispy Kreme and demands money and a
doughnut I don't see man I should live
in Florida do you know this person drunk
naked Florida man sets blank on fire
while baking blank dick pies it's
actually he sets his house on fire well
baking cookies may be said which feels
you bake pies a lot naked right is what
you said so in a way dead man's Blank
and failed bid to unlock his cell phone
dick so his hand was cut off like a
right
Ryan is right although Chris pretty much
gave it to him it's finger they tried to
use his finger to open his phone did it
work I said severed hands that's a lot
well it didn't work and what this was
they kept licking it they made this like
there's now working this way make sure
to LIKE comment subscribe check us out
on Twitter for extra damn day where you
can take another look at it
[Applause]
[Music]